so prime minister the met police has
concluded its uh inquiry are you going
to apologize for the scale of law
breaking and your watch well i'm very
grateful to the met for their uh their
work i thank them for everything that
they've done i think that we we just
need to wait for pursue great to report
and then
as i've said i'll be fingers crossed
that will be uh very soon and i'll be
saying some more next week and can you
guarantee that that report will be as
transparent as possible and that number
10 won't be blocking any names from
being released
that would be entirely up to
sue gray and
will be i'll be
looking for very much to see what she
has to say
and
fingers crossed that will be that will
be pretty soon next week and secondly
what do you say to jamie oliver today
who's protesting outside uh downing
street and eaten mess protests because
of uh you're testing against me no he's
protesting about your obesity policy no
okay we have we are very very uh
we understand the vital importance of of
tackling obesity it costs the nhs
huge huge sums of money uh if people
feel
healthier happier
their quality of life is much much
better if if they lose weight speaking
entirely personally now
there are lots of things you gotta you
gotta focus on uh including uh
diet eating less or eating less is the
most important thing uh but there are
some things at the moment where we think
they make very little difference to
obesity and they can affect people's
weekly outgoings people's budgets and at
this particular time if people can save
on their on their food bills uh with
with some offers then i think we've just
got to be flexible whilst continuing to
tackle obesity you mentioned people
there people hearing whales are
struggling people are struggling
financially food bank use is increasing
what are you waiting for before more
support here we're putting in huge
amounts of support right now and we will
continue to do that the reason we can is
because we came out of kobe with a
strong economy we've got the fiscal
firepower uh to put to put money uh into
into uh people's uh
livelihoods to try to support people you
understand what people are doing
and
the the issue that we have to tackle is
not only the
help for
the immediate costs that cost with
people's energy the cost of
food what you've got to fix
is the uh
the the supply of energy in this country
it is crazy that we're paying so much
more than some other countries for
dependable low carbon uh energy and we
made a historic mistake in not going for
enough nuclear here in wales here in
wales we have the answer so not just at
uh wilford but
but what we also need to do of course
they need help now and i understand that
and
we're helping now and we will continue
to do to do more but at the same time
you've got to show people you've got to
make sure that we don't run into this
kind of problem again and it was the
short termism yeah of previous labour
governments that meant we didn't have
the dependable energy supply factor i
care deeply about the the crunch now but
what we have to avoid
also is future crunches and and future
uh spikes in the cost of energy it is
insane that this country is piping in
electricity uh from the continent from
from france uh crazy when we've got
hydrocarbons of our own and that we're
continuing to take them what
competitions russia what cutbacks have
you had to make personally the last
three months i understand completely
that people are facing a very tough time
and that is why
many many people are facing a very tough
time and that's why we put 22 billion
pounds already
into into tackling
people's costs particularly on energy i
think one thing that people haven't uh
focused on perhaps is that there's
another big cut in
people's
taxes coming everybody on national
insurance contribution uh in july making
that a contributing nationals
and i mix we'll get
an average cut of 330 pounds uh i'm not
look i'm not going to pretend to you
that we can magic away at every single
expense that people are going to face as
a result of the the global spike in
energy prices but be in no doubt that
this will come down we will get people
through it we will use the firepower
that we we've built up
to put our arms around people just as we
did during the pandemic and finally can
i squeak in a question on farmers in
midwest some of them struggling at the
moment with paperwork related to brexit
um when will that improve them well i'm
just hearing a fantastic uh agricultural
food business that is i think uh doing
better and better and we one of the
things we want to do of course is to is
to cut their their their energy costs uh
but there are there are and that will i
think particularly help a a
fantastic business like this but did you
look at uh
lambing sheds uh which i remember from
uh where my family were
were farming you know there are big
expenditures in energy uh inputs like
fertilizer that's that's driven very
much by the uh the cost of
fuel get that down
fix the price of energy and you really
start to help the agricultural sector as
well
that's right
okay